november is nearing which means the next
generation of consoles is
almost here so let's get you all caught
up with a round out of what's in the
boxes
what they're gonna play and when you can
get your hands on them here's everything
you'll need to know about microsoft's
minimalist mini-fridge and sony's
curvaceous popped collar box in order to
compare the two
first up let's do the bit with all the
important numbers
the playstation 5 is fitted with eight
amd zen 2 cpu cores
clocked at a variable frequency of 3.5
gigahertz
comparatively the xbox series x has the
same amd processor
but it's clocked slightly higher at 3.8
gigahertz
in terms of graphics sony's box offers
up 10.3 teraflops
and 36 cus clocked at a variable
frequency of 2.23 gigahertz
while the series x runs with 12.16
teraflops
and 52 cus clocked at 1.825 gigahertz
both boxes are packed with 16 gigabytes
of gddr6 sd
ram a 4k uhd blu-ray optical drive
assuming you opt for the disc included
version of the ps5
a max output resolution of 8k and a
maximum refresh rate of 120 hertz
in terms of storage you should see a
noticeable improvement in load times as
the ps5 comes with an 825 gigabyte ssd
and the xbox series x comes with a one
terabyte ssd
as games continue to get bigger that's
something that may concern you
though both consoles do have slots for
expandable storage
specifically an nvme slot in the ps5
and a one terabyte microsoft expansion
card slot in the series
x it's also worth mentioning that if
you're thinking of opting for the xbox
series s
which only comes with a 512 gigabyte ssd
microsoft is helping you out by making
games up to 30
smaller for the console and so they'll
take up less space
if that's all greek to you don't worry
basically the specs are pretty darn
similar although the xbox series x does
take a slight technical advantage
the most interesting differences are
that at launch the ps5 will only offer
backwards compatibility with the ps4
while series x will be backwards
compatible with the xbox
xbox 360 and xbox one that said the ps5
is launching with vr support while it's
sounding less and less likely that the
series x will do the same
according to a sound byte from xbox boss
phil spencer last year where he said
we're responding to what our customers
are asking for and nobody's asking for
vr
both consoles also support ray tracing
which enables them to better simulate
light in games
and most importantly both are a serious
upgrade over their predecessors
so that's the two boxes covered now
let's dig into the all-important
controllers
the ps5's dual sense controller looks to
be quite a bit different to the ps4s
dualshock 4.
the controller includes haptic feedback
adaptive triggers that can add
resistance based on the game
as well as a speaker and touchpad much
like that of the dualshock 4.
it's a little chunkier than its sibling
so if you're a playstation fan who
always hoped sony would add a little
more bulk to their controllers
this could be right up your alley as for
the xbox series x its controller is a
little smaller than its predecessor but
otherwise it's almost
identical the only new things of note
are a share button and a hybrid 4-way
and 8-way directional pad
your xbox one controllers will also work
on series x
and your series x controller can be used
on xbox one
comparatively while the dualshock 4 can
be used on ps5 to play ps4 games with
backwards compatibility
you won't be able to use it to play ps5
games
xbox live gold and playstation plus are
making a return but things get a little
more complicated than that for next gen
microsoft have confirmed that both the
xbox series x and
sirius s will be available through
xbox's all-access subscription
service here you can pay 25 usd a month
for series s
or 35 usd a month for the series x over
a period of 24 months
and you'll also get game pass ultimate
included that's a combo of game pass for
both xbox and pc
ea play xcloud and xbox live gold
for the ps5 sony has revealed the plus
collection a library of some of the
ps4's best games that will be freely
available to plus subscribers
the collection includes games like god
of war bloodborne days gone persona 5
and resident evil 7.
the plus collection is exclusive to the
ps5 while it's certainly not as beefy of
an offering as microsoft's xbox game
pass
there's some really good stuff in there
so check out the full list in our story
on gamespot
as for gaming on the cloud if that's
your thing ps5 will presumably continue
to offer its playstation now service
and xbox series x will work with
microsoft project xcloud
as the service is bundled with xbox game
pass ultimate
now we're sufficiently covered up on how
you'll be playing the games
let's dig into what shall we playing
xbox series x will support smart
delivery for select titles where you can
download a series x
optimized version of a game for free if
you own it on xbox one
smart delivery titles include cyberpunk
2077
assassin's creed valhalla chorus and
yakuza like a dragon
outside of smart delivery the xbox
series x launch lineup includes gears
tactics
nba 2k 21 fifa 21 and fortnite
in 2021 and beyond xbox series x is
scheduled to get halo infinite
forza motorsport the ascent and senegal
saga hellblade 2.
on the playstation side launch titles
will include spider-man miles morales
the demon souls remake sac boy a big
adventure
astros playroom assassin's creed
valhalla destruction all-stars
and fortnite console exclusives arriving
on the platform later on will include
horizon forbidden west
ratchet and clank rift apart and of
course bug snacks
if you're looking for more complete
lists of what you can play on next
generation consoles
do check out our videos covering off on
every game coming to ps5
and xbox series x respectively as for
the all-important release date and price
point the xbox series x is due out on
november 10th
and will run you 499 bucks in the us
while the playstation 5 will also run
you 499 bucks
and 399 for its diskless version
it's out on november the 12th
microsoft's tiny less powerful diskless
offering the xbox series s
will also be available on november 10th
but for 299 dollars in the us
250 pounds in the uk and 499
in australia you're probably not from
australia but i just wanted you to know
consoles are expensive here
pre-orders for microsoft's next-gen
consoles alive on september 22nd while
ps5 pre-orders are live now if you can
manage to find somebody with stock
let me know down in that comment box if
you're planning on getting a next
generation console which one
and why as always we'll keep you covered
off on everything ps5
xbox series x and everything else that
matters in gaming
you